all right so this talk is about faster
non-convex dog has become ization than
SPD with a subtitle how to swing by set
of points so first of all I want to
thank the organizers for inviting me to
give the talk and the organizing the
workshop I really learned a lot
including something towards the end of
the talk will actually reflect what I
learned the day before yesterday so
let's see good
so this talk is about something the
following problem that is to minimize an
unconstrained non convex function in
facts
so without loss of generality I'm going
to write FX as an average over functions
F 1 F 2 and your FN okay it's without
loss of generality because n can
definitely be 1 but actually in many
many applications and its really huge
especially in like training a neural
network actually regardless of how
complex the neural network looks like
the problem of training a neural network
is nothing but minimizing a function
like this well n here corresponds to the
number of input training input training
data for instance if we're doing some
convolution on your network if we have
like a million images to Train
then each F I could just correspond to
the last value with respect to the 8th
input training image and therefore like
n could be you know a million in this
example so some people also write it as
an expectation over function f I which
allows the index I to really be joined
from an infinite set so throughout this
talk I would also be able to support
that but just for notational simplicity
I'm going to write them as like an
average over you know functions F 1 and
your FM but feel free to think about n
being infinite in this talk so that's
the problem I want to solve
so in this non convex word so what is
our goal right so perhaps the simplest
goal is to find approximate local
minimum sorry approximate stationary
point meaning a point that has vanished
in gradient this is goal number one but
we also know that a stationary point may
be either a local minima or a saddle
point and especially motivated from a
lot of practical examples in deep
learning we know that the low set of
points are really not so great so we
want to also avoid that
that sorry oh yeah in principle oh come
back - no but that's not very likely to
happen so let me just define set a point
to be you know both set of points and
local Maxima okay there for like a
second more ambitious goal is to find an
approximate local minima which are
pictures like this so this will be the
main focus of today's torque although
like let me still spend one more slide
to mention about even more ambitious
goals like such as approximately finding
safe global minima so we know that this
problem is simply hard but there really
exists a lot of heuristics that reduce
this task number three to test number
two such as graduated optimization
suppose we want to minimize function f
three sitting here and if we use an
arbitrary local minima algorithm to find
a local minima then we may get stuck
either here or here or here or here so
that may not be so great and the whole
theory of graduated optimization says
that what we can do is to smoothen the
objective by a random perturbation so
say that we define a new function f
prime to be the same as before except
that we add a random perturbation theta
vector which is drawn from which is
going from like a bore of radius R so if
the radius is large then we get function
1 if the Rydia is small we get function
2 and so forth so the theory of graduate
the optimization says the following that
is instead of directly minimizing
function 3 we can first use a local
minima algorithm to optimize function
number 1 so we get this point then we
will reduce the radius and we go to
function number 2 and then we find a
local minima and we continue in this
fashion
so this heuristic really works very well
in practice and it could help us to
successfully avoid some very poor local
minima
including you know the ones that sit on
top like this ones so once you're smooth
and the objective you know bad local
minima will go away but still we have
the issue about you know maybe the
algorithm we're falling to either this
local minimum or that one so that comes
the other heuristic that is to do random
seeding so if you generate enough random
seeds then in practice you can also get
a reason
better local minima without further
overdue let me just state that even if
you're interested in this more ambitious
goal of number three
still this talk can be relevant all
right so the talk is about achieving
goal number two so let us see like
what're the prior works so pretty much
like the only like online result sitting
here is stochastic gradient descent
which also happens to be what everyone
now uses in training neural networks so
stock has take gradient descent I claim
that he finds an epsilon approximate
local minima which I'm going to define
later in this number of rounds one over
epsilon to the fourth power okay so
throughout this talk by saying one round
I mean one back propagation that is if
you have a neural network of say this
size then once you have an input image
or input data then you do a back
propagation just on that input only okay
so that's one back propagation so one
round means one back propagation so this
result was essentially first shown by
wrong good at or although they in their
current version of the archive they only
prove the result that poly dimension
over absolute or fourth power but I was
taught that the original authors are on
the way to get rid of the poly D factor
and we also know how to prove that but
however we will wait for the original
authors to publish an updated version so
throughout this talk I'm going to refer
to as PD to have this complexity order
one over epsilon to the fourth power in
this start I'm going to introduce an
algorithm that we can attach a to that
can find the same kind of local minima
in a smaller number of rounds without
additional assumptions so you mean goal
number one in this one yeah so I will
come back to that maybe not immediately
but in a few slides
so to give you a prediction okay there
are three necessary assumptions in order
to achieve any minimal minimal
meaningful conclusion about local
minimum one is the variance of the
gradient has to be bounded to the
function has to be smooth otherwise like
you may not net say like you haven't
liked function like this
if the gradient changes too much then
you know finding a point with smoke
gradient necessarily means that you have
to exactly find this point and therefore
like even achieving goal one requires a
smoothness and also one needs
second-order smoothness to claim
anything useful about local minima but I
will come back to that slide later okay
so I will mention about about the
assumptions so at this point let me make
a quick remark those two results have
their complexities to be really
independent of them
so this is what we refer to as Ally
results so this is in contrast to some
other algorithms like foo gradient
descent and so on and so forth in which
the complexities have some polynomial
dependency on N for instance like n to
the 2/3 and to the 3/4 but this torque
is pretty much only about the online
methods but towards the end of the talk
I will also give you a survey about what
are the known results hours and others
regarding the offline setting ok the
reason we want to really focus on the
online setting is because you know n
could be really huge not only like n
could come from the number of input
state training beta it could also come
from say graduated optimization so if we
do a perturbation of the function the in
principle there suddenly becomes like
infinite number of functions that we're
averaging about at releasing principal
and therefore like designing a line
algorithm is really very important so
this is the method I'm going to
introduce so throughout this talk I am
NOT doing any mini-batch version of
anything but in principle even if you
have an algorithm that has like say an N
dependency if you do mini batch I don't
think that gives you an N independent
result even if like your mini batch size
is like square root N or something
that's huge not not that we are aware of
I think at this point in the convex case
that becomes a little more and more
possible nowadays
so before I go into any technical
details let me just first like mention a
very intuitive kind of approach using
pictures remember our goal here is to
find a local minima so this goal
naturally we reduce us to actually the
following two tasks others let us first
try to find an approximate stationary
point which is really go number one but
now suppose we have found a stationary
point then there are two possibilities
case one it's a local minima in such a
case we're done right case number two if
we really are currently inside like a
state of point then we need to
necessarily escape from the set of point
so what do I mean by escaping from set
of point is really like go in this
direction which corresponds to the
negative has an negative eigen vector of
the Hessian of the of the current point
and we wish to really escape from that
so this was the idea that that is pretty
much used in the prior work and let me
elaborate that a little more again using
pictures what is this business of
escaping from set of points so suppose
that I draw the gradient flow of a
function around a set of point then
necessarily there exist at least one
direction in which the gradient drives
us out of the set of point and one
direction that drives us say towards the
saddle point okay I'm only drawing two
dimensions but in principle the
dimension can be high so now a critical
observation here is that as long as you
start from a point that is not really on
this central line for instance here even
if it's very close as long as you follow
the path of the gradient of the function
you can escape from set of point okay
this is always true but what comes
difficult here is what is this rate of
escaping from set of point so you can
imagine that the closer you start from
from a point near the central vertical
line and then the slower the algorithm
escapes from to the point and this
really comes now this idea of random
perturbation that says because of this
effect like my point can be close to the
vertical line then what
if I do random perturbation suppose I
say perturb the point inside a unit or
of in the D dimensional space then we
know by you know concentration theorems
with very high chance we're not going to
landing anything inside this belt and
therefore like after perturbation our
points could be either on the left or on
the right in such a case we have
abounded a lower bound about how close
the point is to the central vertical
line and we can prove a rate of escaping
from to the point so this was this idea
of escaping from set of points in which
previously researchers have really
proved the bounds about that and showed
that the stochastic gradient descent
plus random perturbation can escape from
to the point in this number of runs and
this year they showed that gradient
descent can escape from this number of
runs so the first one is an online
complexity the second one is an offline
complexity okay so this is the business
of escaping from set a point so in
today's talk I want to promote a new
notion that is to swing by a set of
point okay so I borrowed this
terminology really from high school
physics or maybe middle school primary
school for some of you so remember that
we learned if we send a spaceship to the
universe and suppose we want to make a
turn right then the most energy
efficient way is not to directly make
the term but to swing by a planet like
this so therefore can we actually also
swing by a say the point so here's what
I mean
suppose we are currently at a point like
here okay then maybe we are moving like
upwards then somehow if we can magically
have a telescope that tells us yet it's
like in our path in our trajectory very
soon we are going to hit a stationary
hit a set of point so if we can somehow
have such an like crazy telescope then
immediately like we have a warning that
is if we don't do anything we're going
to crash into this set of point and then
we have to escape from it and it can be
energy inefficient a very natural thing
at this point to do is to give the
spaceship a kick and once you
you are here then this time like you can
just swing by the settle point if you
follow say the gradient flow so of
course like a lot of technical details
are missing here especially what is this
telescope and what is this path and
things can become like even more crazy
if we only have stochastic gradients
rather than the exact gradient of the
function so these are the technical
details that our filling in the rest of
the talk okay so at this point I'm ready
to talk about assumptions before I go
into the details notice I'm going to
make three necessary assumptions the
first assumption is I'm going to assume
the variance of this stochastic gradient
is bounded okay that is if you take a
random I then the expectation of this
vector minus the true gradient this is
bounded so I claim this as a necessary
assumption because think about it if
this is the gradient of the function but
if your variance is really infinite so
that every iteration if you make a query
like you can make a very large kind of
error then you necessarily have to put
your step lines to converge to zero or
to really be something close to zero and
therefore you don't get very good
convergence right and therefore like
we're really happy to make to make
assumption on the variance of the of the
stochastic gradient and this was also
assumed by all different variants of
stochastic gradient descent so we're
happy to assume this yeah so in this
talk to make things like the notations
simple I'm assuming like uniform
sampling from the f eyes but it can
actually be drawn from a distribution in
such a way like you have to really find
the same say it's uniform like over all
the points if it's not I guess you can
if you happen to know like how the
variance behaves in different places you
can maybe change your learning rate at
different places to be to be adaptive to
such values but for this torque say that
we have a uniform bound okay
you have this funny virus and you want
to do mini-batch it's the exercise
depend on and so in principle you can do
the mini better size for any size you
want so if you have a larger size if you
have a larger size then the value the
variance really can be reduced by a good
factor but a few other things may not
necessarily be reduced so I'm happy to
talk offline to tell you like how things
progress so in the in short like so in
this three other store camera zoom in
the mini batch size to be one just for
the simplicity of presenting everything
of course like one Camry so for nearly
all variants of like first other
optimization algorithms including the
ones today we can we can include
mini-batch and the same proof we'll go
through then the question is like that's
the number of iterations really reduced
by this factor of the mini batch or not
I'm happy to talk offline more about
this so that's the first assumption the
second assumption is Lipsius smoothness
thatis the gradient of the function
doesn't change too much if I move from X
to Y then the gradient changes by a
factor that's at most a parameter L
times X minus y again like it's a
uniform constant L for simplicity this
again I claim it's necessary because if
you ever want to because if the function
is not loops are smooth it could be like
this then if you ever want to find an
approximate a stationary point with even
absolute being 0.5 that necessarily
means that you have to find this point
exactly but that could be impossible
yeah just because like you know as an
adversary I can hide this point to a
place that the algorithm doesn't ever
even make chorister function and so on
yeah
so I need the double-sided version from
both so this one implies that the hassen
is bounded both from above and below yes
that's true so I'm just doing a very
simple example as hard instance
so therefore like in other words to make
any conclusive statement about vanish
ingredient what really needs the
smoothness about the function so this is
also assumed by SVD in the non convex
setting okay if the convex setting is
not needed but in the non convex setting
the convergence rate has really really
also assumes liquor smoothness so for
similar reason I'm also going to assume
second-order smoothness in this torque
meaning that the Hessian also doesn't
changed too fast so this is for the
similar reason as before that is in
order to make any conclusive statement
about second order information meaning
like a local minima so that talks about
the Hessian then I have to assume that
hasn't doesn't jump you know from a
point to a point nearby so those are
really necessary assumptions and also
record by prior work sound SVD in a non
convex setting okay so for simplicity in
this torque I'm assuming all the three
parameters are one just to make the
notation simple in the full paper you
can see you know how the parameters also
show up okay it is good for the
assumptions all right let me now begin
with task number one that is what it's
really this telescope okay so by
definition what is a set of point a set
a point is a point in which if you
compute its hash Ian it has a negative
strictly negative eigen value so in
other words if we have a delta strict
set of point that means at least one of
the eigen values is below some threshold
negative Delta now by the second-order
smoothness of the function we know that
if we move to any point whose distance
to access at most say Delta over two
then at that point there's also a
negative vegam value that is below minus
Delta over two in other words at any
point say Y suppose we can find a unit
norm vector V
such that V transpose the hats in times
V is less or equal to minus Delta over
two this gives us in some sense our
certificate of we're being really close
to a set of point in fact mathematically
we can do something very simple that is
once you have obtained later I'm going
to say how to obtain such a vector but
once you have obtained such a vector
then we can continue to do a kick the
kick means that we either go in the
direction of V or we go in the direction
of negative V with the step lines Delta
and say with imprison you can choose to
either go the positive or negative
direction whichever that decreases the
objective better but in theory you can
just choose the sign to be random either
go left or go right to one of the two
then you can show that in expectation
the objective decreases by an amount
which is at least a constant times Delta
to the third power so this is a
consequence of the second-order
smoothness that only requires two lines
to prove okay so this is there for the
cake but still I haven't solved the
question about how to find such a vector
V okay let me now really abstract away
this problem okay
using just language of matrices but that
hasn't so suppose we have a matrix M
that can be written as a stock Catholic
form so it's an average of M eyes then
this yellow box is an independent
problem about finding the most positive
eigen value of M so if we can solve this
yellow box then we can simply set the M
to be the negative hessian and mi to be
the negative has enough fi and then we
can solve the original problem and
therefore on the next few slides i am
going to talk about this a problem that
may be of independent interest that is
we have a stochastic matrix and we wish
to find the most positive eigen value of
that matrix okay we want to find it as
fast as possible but what do I mean by
fast by fast I really mean two things
first I want the complexity to be online
meaning that I wanted to be independent
of n the number of pieces to more
importantly I wish to support only
computations that are matrix vector
products meaning that whenever I compute
M I
times say an arbitrary vector W then I
increase my complexity by one okay the P
counts the number of matrix vector
products with respect to those like M
eyes not with respect to M but with
respect to M eyes in other words I wish
to construct an algorithm that has the
smallest value T as a function of the
approximation error the reason I want to
you know restrict myself to this model
but not allowing things like you know
explicitly storing the matrix or matrix
inversion it's really because of the
following reason in that we can view
like in two different angles on white
hand from the field of approximation
algorithms we all know that computing
matrix vector product is cheap that
takes only a and Z time which is the
number of non-zeros of the
representation of the matrix so you know
for instance David Woodruff has been
explaining like why this is important
quite a number of times and once on
Tuesday so like even if like from from a
different angle back to the original
question about each and I being really
the Hessian of some function fi I claim
that this is also very important here to
restrict ourselves only to operations
like this so suppose that each function
you know once we are minimizing a
function then the function has to be
given to us right suppose each function
is described in a description size s
meaning that it's described by a size s
arithmetic circuit then I climb that
claim two things first computing as
gradient requires only a linear time in
terms of the input description size of
the function this is really because of
the chain rule of derivatives which is
known as back propagation emerging
learning but something that perhaps a
little bit less well known is the fact
that computing matrix vector product or
product can also be done in linear time
in terms of the input description size
so this was actually discovered more
than 30 years ago published in neural
computations and now for instance using
like the tensor flow package you only
need two lines with one back propagation
or two depending on the
imitation then you can support
computations like this in the same
complexity as computing the gradient
okay for this reason I really wish to
study this restricted computational
model that is to support only matrix
vector products in terms of finding the
most say the most positive eigen value
of M so this is a task of independent
interest so let's see how to solve it
perhaps the most natural thing that
comes to everyone's mind is power method
record that power method without loss of
generality assumes all the matrices to
be PSD if not you add a multiple of
identity to make it PSD then the top
acre vector doesn't change you know and
here's how power method power method
works
we initialize with random vector then we
keep multiplying the matrix m to the
left of V zero say P times in the very
end if we normalize the vector then we
have a guarantee that as V transpose MB
MV is at least one minus Epsilon
multiplicative approximation to the
largest eigenvalue of the matrix as
small as t is larger than equal to one
over epsilon so this is a very simple to
prove folklore result about power method
that's in our case we cannot really
allow computations of you know m times a
vector we can only support like M I
times a vector therefore like can we
have a stochastic version of the power
method perhaps the most natural thing to
do is to replace each M with M I so we
know in expectation M equals to the
expectation of Emma right but this idea
doesn't work because even though this
final vector V T in expectation is good
but its variance is really huge like it
dominates like the expectation of the
value and therefore like you do not get
any meaningful information out of this
process so somehow the correct
stochastic version of power method is
the following originally discovered by
olya also like from the community of
biology and neuroscience that is instead
of multiplying mi which is too
aggressive in each iteration we multiply
it by identity
plus a positive learning rate either
times mi okay well either you can think
about it that's something that's pretty
small or something 1 over root T the
number of iterations that kind of
quantity so this is oh yes algorithm as
you can see like this matrix in
expectation is identity plus either
times M so still like if you view this
as an instance of power method then the
final vector should align to some extent
to the largest eigen vector of identity
plus ETA times M which is the same
vector as M the largest eigen vector of
M right and therefore incredibly this
algorithm should converge so this is
called odious algorithm unfortunately
the convergence rate of OS algorithm was
not really well understood until this
year so with co-author and Julie we
finally showed that if you apply
yourself with them with a fixed learning
rate if you choose the learning rate to
be 1 over root T then in the very end if
you normalize the vector V T you get an
additive Delta approximation in just 1
over Delta square runs and this turns
out to be optimal information
theoretically ok so let me make a few
remarks first so far the proof is really
not intimidating it's only one page
proof but it comes as a it's kind of a
one-page tricky proof that comes as a
by-product of our follow the compress
leader framework which deals with the
the same case but even the matrices can
be the MIS can be chosen like
adversarially so it's a more difficult
setting but as a by-product in the very
last section of that paper we have a one
page proof of this this result so that
is nice and this this proof was also
motivated by a very beautiful work of
Jing of jang jinguk ad natural poly and
support in which they show that OS a
algorithm has a convergence rate that
doesn't look like this but assuming the
matrix has an icon cap between the first
and the second eigen values but this
result we showed here has no even gap
assumption so that's the that's the
point here and finally like even if you
want to find say not the top one acre
vector by the top say 10 or
you know 28 vectors there exist a block
version of OS algorithm that also allows
you to do it that becomes much much much
more involved to prove so it's a 60 page
proof that's going to appear like in ten
days in this year's fox if you're
interested I can I would talk about that
in that torque so this is really the
remarks I want to make here about this
algorithm so the that's a good question
so in order to get this result in some
sense we need the variance of M I to be
bounded but that's really a byproduct of
the fact that each mi has a bounded
bounded spectral norm but that's
actually a consequence of delipcious
movements of the functions okay so it
does not come from the variance of the
gradients but it comes from the
smoothness it's like the zero order
first order second order assumptions
this comes from the first order
assumption alright so that is a result
to put it back to this picture about the
telescope now we know exactly what this
telescope is that is an algorithmic
procedure which is oh yes algorithm that
says let's do 1 over Delta squirrel
rounds or in other words one of the
Delta Squad back propagations we can
either find a unit norm vector V such
that V transpose the hats in times V is
less or equal to minus say Delta over 2
in such a case we do a kick and we can
decrease the objective by Delta cube or
if we do not find such a vector it
necessarily means that the Hessian at
the current point has all the
eigenvalues larger than n equal to say
minus Delta you see like there is a
delta cap between the two things and
that's the additive approximation error
on the previous page right so now like
if we if we run into the second case
that as we conclude all the eigenvalues
are large we wish to essentially do this
and now comes task number two that is
what is this path ok let me rewrite this
problem that is we are currently at a
point X 0 that has all the eigen values
of the Hessian being larger than equal
to
this threshold minus Delta and then we
wish to find a point that is an
approximate local minima yep but the
vector V in that previous slide do you
choose one fixed V and keep using order
using a different random V in each round
so so let me since I have reloaded the
definition of round let me see it
differently so at any point for instance
if I'm here I compute a new V
corresponding to the Hessian of the
current point after I have moved to
either do a kick or maybe I have moved
later than actually in a number of
iterations later I'm going to invoke
this process again at a different point
and therefore it would be a different V
good question so this problem is now
like I have a starting point with all
the Hessians values of there hasn't been
large there I wish to find an
approximate local minima which means
that it has a vanishing gradient and all
the ego values of the Hessian are larger
than equal to some threshold minus Delta
so this is what we say an epsilon Delta
approximate local minima so towards this
at the end of the talk I'm going to pick
Delta as well but at this point that
let's think about the problem as a Babel
approximation so we have two parameters
one is epsilon and one is Delta so let's
abstract it away at this point so this
is the goal and I claim that this
problem actually reduces to a seemingly
much simpler problem which is to achieve
the same goal but this time instead of
assuming that only at the starting point
I have all the eigenvalues of the hasn't
been large but I have the eigenvalues of
the Hansons being large for all the
points in the space ok so I claim that
the first task actually reduces to this
second and task that is at least from
definition easier so this reduction was
explicitly given by Carmen do Chi hinder
and set forth and implicitly given by us
in like two papers that appeared on the
same day archive and here is how this
reduction works first of all a simple
observation I can get rid of this part
because I already have the other
that all points have to have sins a
values of there hasn't been large and
therefore I can't get rid of this point
okay now I want to show this problem
reduces to this so there are two things
I need to share first I need to
construct a new function f from this
function little F okay and then I need I
need to show that function satisfies
this property that's the first step to
prove a reduction the second step is to
close the loop and show that any
algorithm that finds me a point
satisfying this I can turn it into a
solution to the original problem so this
is a reduction right if I can
successfully show this this is a
reduction let me first say the first
thing that is how to define this new
function big f so I'm using this
language of our common network so they
define the function big f to be the same
as little F everywhere like inside a
unit or inside the ball with radius
Delta so this rad regularization term
you can see that it's zero whenever the
point is close enough to X zero and how
close it's by distance Delta so whenever
you have a point that's inside this
board then I do not make any changes to
the function okay if I am outside this
board then I add a quadratic penalising
term which turns out to be the distance
minus Delta this whole quantity square
so this is the definition of big f that
has appeared in the result of cameto
so now let me prove to you that this
function satisfies this property for all
the points in the space there are only
two cases if the point is inside the
bore then we know that big F is the same
as little F and that claim that for
every point inside the bore then the ego
values of the Hessian are above say
negative three Delta throughout the
torque I'm ignoring constants so if I
prove three Delta it's the same thing
here okay so the reason is as follows
and the very original point X 0 I have
this minimum eigen value of the of the
Hashem is above minus Delta now by the
smoothness namely the second-order
smoothness of the function if I move by
a distance of
then yes there has income change but it
cannot change too much and therefore it
can be maybe at most to Delta or say 3
Delta to be safe and therefore the
minimum eigen value if you move from X 0
to anything inside the bore remains to
be lower bounded by something that minus
a constant times Delta then for any
point outside the bore I claim that the
Hessian of this new function has all the
eigen values being non-negative this is
because big f is the summation of little
F and the rad term here so the little F
function because it is first-order
smooth that means all the eager values
are lower bounded by say minus 1
remember I assume the smoothness to be 1
for simplicity and then the red term has
all the the red term is exactly
quadratic if it's outside the board and
therefore like the red term has has been
being at least 1 for all the AYGO values
and therefore if you sum them up by
additive 'ti you get 0 ok so that proves
this new function big f satisfies that
all the eigen values of all the points
are above threshold minus say 3 Delta I
in order to show this is the reduction I
need to close the loop and show that as
long as I have an algorithm that for
this big F problem can help me find a
point with vanish ingredient then I can
turn this point into a solution to the
original problem
ok here is why suppose I have found a
point satisfying this then there are
again two possibilities this one if this
point is inside the board then I claim
we're done because every point in the
bore has its eigen values of the Hessian
being large and therefore we have solved
the original problem ok so that's case
one case two if the point is outside the
bar then I claim that we also weighing
but for a different reason we do not
directly solve this but we win by some
other measure of performance which is
think about it if we have an algorithm
that moves from X 0 to to this point X
then as far as the algorithm is like
you're visibly defined then it has to
decrease the objective that necessarily
means
that this the objective big F on this
new point ax should be less than or
equal to the objective of the point I
started with whatever this is true I
claim that we win because big F is the
same as the small F at the starting
point but there's a red penalizing term
sitting here on the left hand side that
means if this point say X is say to
doubt away from X 0 then the red
penalizing term will be say Delta square
that means if you look at its term FX is
less or equal to FX 0 minus Delta square
that means we have decreased the
objective by Delta square and therefore
like we also win this is a very informal
description about how this reduction
works in other words like we either find
a point that is already a local minima
or if we fail then we have to decrease
the objective by some significant amount
so therefore like this problem now what
it remains two for me to do is in this
talk it's really to you know propose a
solution to solve this problem let me
now rewrite the problem that is we have
a function instead of using the big f
let me just use this more F so I have a
function small F that's an average of
device but now I have the assumption
that is this function has the eigen
value of the Hessian being large for all
different points above some threshold
minus Delta and I wish to find a point
with vanishing gradient so this again
becomes a problem of independent
interest and if you can solve it fast
you can solve the problem of local
minima fast so a little bit into like
notations so we know that immersion
learning including the previous start we
have seen a lot of use of the word
strong convexity so we say that a
function is strongly convex essentially
if it's Hessian has all the eigen values
above some positive threshold Sigma in
the remainder of the talk I want to
introduce a new notion called called
strong non convexity I say the function
as Delta strongly non convex if all the
eigen values of the Hessian at all the
points above some negative threshold
minus Delta so this is just an
Negus to the strong convexity above then
instance the blue curve here is 0.2
strongly non-convex and the yellow term
here is 1 strongly non-convex that just
makes my verbal explanation faster I
don't need to carry around the word you
know Egan values of the has an all the
time so as you can imagine the larger
this parameter Delta is then the more
convex sorry the more non convex the
function becomes and therefore it should
become harder for an algorithm to
converge so this is precisely the thing
I want to study that is I wish to study
like can we have a complexity bound for
instance for first order methods so that
it can take advantage of this value of
Delta for instance II can it be a curve
that you know increases as a function of
Delta it turns out that for most of the
prior works this is not true for
instance stock has the gradient descent
is sit here
that means stochastic gradient descent
can find a point with gradient at most
epsilon in 1 over epsilon to the 4th
iterations but somehow in a few slides
I'm going to elaborate why that somehow
stochastic gradient descent cannot take
advantage of this parameter of Delta
even if the function are feeding to SPD
is Delta strongly convex and even if the
function even if the algorithm knows the
value of Delta still it cannot take
advantage of Delta at least in theory ok
some other method this was a
breakthrough the result by lady Chen and
Jordan record their algorithm SCS G but
it's essentially a variant of SVR G in
which they show that you can get
whatever epsilon to the tail birth
reasoning here again this algorithm
doesn't take advantage of Delta so what
we proposed in this paper as really a
byproduct is a method that we coordinate
at 1.5
that achieves this curve so in the very
right hand it matches the best known
result of SC s G but on the left and the
complexity can reduce but there's a
barrier of 1 epsilon cube that we cannot
overcome so this is this result of
Natasha 1.5 but why is such a curve
helpful so let me illustrate
using again this picture of swinging by
settle points so suppose we have a
telescope that can help us detect all
the set of points with parameter 10
Delta then I claim that yes we can still
swing by set of points but we can only
swing by a delight very slowly but if we
have a stronger telescope that can take
attacks all the set of points with
parameter minus delta that means we can
detect more set of points and therefore
if you follow a path whatever the path
is then you should intuitively expect
the path to be faster because this time
we know more information about the
potential set of points around us and
therefore we should be able to make use
of such information and go faster to
swing by the settle point and this is
precisely the point of a curve like this
that is if this parameter is smaller
meaning that we can detect more set of
points then we should have a speed which
is smaller we should have a complexity
that are smaller okay and if we have a
larger parameter delta then we should
run slower and therefore like whenever
one can get a converging a convergence
curve like this taking advantage of
Delta then we can translate this into a
useful algorithm for finding approximate
local minimum so in a 45-minute talk I
don't think I have time to exactly
describe the algorithm but still let me
use one slide to give you some pictures
about why this is potentially possible
so I'm going to use the language of
linear coupling that Lorenz are recchia
and I have been proposing really for
three years now now that we divide
really first other methods and first
other analysis into two categories the
first category is what we call gradient
descent type of analysis and the second
category is what we call mirror design
type of analysis so in an uncle for
non-convex function gradient descent
means the following that is at any
points the XK we can draw a quadratic
upper bound of the function that is
tangent to the current gradient of the
function at the current point so this
rap quadratic function is uniquely
defined so that is tangent to the
gradient hyperplane and also has a
curvature one
so by the smoothness of the function we
know this rat curve is an upper bound to
the original function and therefore if
we compute the minimizer of this
function and call it XK plus one then we
can move there and that guarantees us to
decrease the objective by this quantity
so whenever an algorithm and this
underlying analysis uses you know some
analysis like this then we say it's a
great n descent type of analysis so this
is in contrast to a different class of
first of the methods that we summarize
as mirror the same type of algorithms in
which the instead of upper bounding of
function they try to lower bound the
function in the following sense at every
single point you can compute the
gradient which is a hyperplane right in
the D dimensional space now if the
function is convex then we know this is
the lower bound a hyperplane to the
function at all points the whole theory
of mirror descent in the convex setting
is saying that we can somehow make
intelligent queries at different points
so that hoping that in the end we have a
number of linear lower bounding hyper
planes and then we make use of that to
somehow get some convergence for first
other methods so the mathematics is
actually a bit harder to describe at
this part I just want to use this
picture to describe your descent in a
very informal sense and already we can
observe something very interesting it's
going to happen for non convex
optimization
now there's in a non convex case we
cannot use this lower bound because it's
not a lower bound to the function but
instead if you draw a quadratic lower
bound which is a function that's tangent
to this to this gradient hyperplane but
with curvature negative one then by the
smoothness of the function we know this
is a lower bound to the original non
convex function so this is something we
proposed in last year that is a non
convex generalization of Muir descent
and therefore if you make different
curries you get different lower bounds
and somehow if you intelligently make
use of a combination of such lower
bounds
you can also prove something about
vanishing gradient so this is something
we discover the last year but what is
now very interesting here is that
suppose you have Delta strong non
convexity then the lower
getting proved if Delta is say 0.1 then
the curvature curvature here becomes
negative point one but unfortunately the
upper bounds the quadratic are programs
like this it never get improved because
you know that's about the upper
smoothness of the function in contrast
to the lower smoothness of the function
and therefore an algorithm if it uses
created ascent type of analysis then it
cannot make take advantage of this value
of Delta so this is why for instance
stochastic gradient descent and SCS G
they cannot really take advantage of
Delta and this is this was the whole
point of proposing a new algorithm that
we couldn't attach 1.5 that achieves
this curve so I don't have time to
describe the algorithm but this is how
it behaves so on the last slide let me
just describe the pseudocode of natasha
- okay very simple here is how it works
starting from any point X we first try
to use OS algorithm to detect whether or
not we have a unit vector so that the
vector V transpose that has in times V
is less or equal to say minus Delta over
2 if we found that then we do a peak
that is to go in the direction of either
plus V or minus V and we can guarantee
to decrease the objective by Delta cube
okay that's something I lose crediting
the first half of the talk but if no
that necessarily means that at the
current point the Hessian has all the
eigen values being above the threshold
and in this case we invoke Natasha 1.5
which helps us to find a point with
vanish ingredient then we also hope that
this point is close to X because if so
then we have this X prime not only
satisfying vanish ingredient but also
because being close to X it also has all
the eigen values being large so
therefore again there are two cases if
we succeed if we successfully found a
point that's X prime satisfying this and
near X then we're done because that
point is an approximate local minima but
if not remember like that guarantees us
to in some sense also decrease the
objective and if you dig into the mass
this
how much you can decrease so in the very
end you just this is the Attar
description of the algorithm and
therefore if you do the parameters
between the two cases this is the final
theorem you can prove that as natasha to
finds an epsilon delta local minima in
this number of rounds or this number of
back propagation as a simple corollary
if you choose Delta to be epsilon to the
1 over 4 then the number of back
propagation is absolutely to the minus 3
point 2 5 so in optimization we
sometimes say that the point is absent
approximately local minima as well as
Delta is less or equal to epsilon to
some constant power and here in this
result epsilon is 4 but don't worry too
much because even in our prior work this
constant is at least 4 so for instance
SGD finds this type of local minima with
a constant C that's not very explicit in
the paper but believed to be at least 4
in this number of rounds and therefore
this this corollary is a strict
improvement over stochastic gradient
descent so I know I'm running out of
time so let me know like put everything
in the table so what do we have I'm the
in the in the in the whole field of
online non combat stochastic
optimization we have algorithms that
find stationary points an algorithm that
find local minima so SGD if you use it
only to find stationary point this is
the number of rounds and se s3 has this
number of rounds a 3d plus perturbation
has life for a chips local minima in
this number of rounds and Natasha torch
sits here so not touch of 1.5 actually
sits here with the parameter Delta and
this is the curve that I draw earlier so
actually now comes also the point for
open questions so actually in the convex
case one can use a 3d to achieve upper
bound which is epsilon to the negative
two point five but to the best of my
knowledge the lower bound is absolute to
the negative two so even in the convex
case we don't know what is the best rate
yet for finding a point that has
vanished in gradient and not to say that
in the non convex word you know what do
we what is really the optimal thing so
these results are assumed like bonded
very and smoothness for the second-order
smoothness you only need it if you want
local minima so
that's a summary for the for the online
case and they're sexually similar
picture you can find in the paper about
the offline setting which are the
algorithm that have complexity that
depends on n so these are the best no
results so far thank you so much I hope
you have enjoyed the process of swinging
by us at a point delayed I mean we're
finishing anyway some things we don't
know I think would probably make
questions but just even yeah I think
also for some reason none of the
organizers are here but yeah thanks for
all the stickers and
[Applause]